i i've never thought of you as like like
just like watching youtube videos just
you know i'm getting ready to talk to
you today
like
it was like i was like wait like blood
stuff like gang [ __ ] like i just never
thought of you that way you know like oh
yeah uh i was running wild before we
were making records um i was
how you know i guess i was considered a
badass kid
you know i was i was very uh to myself
but when i got involved with the gangs i
was pretty much a soldier you know
and uh
with with within a gang you have your
own gang you know so let's just say
there's 200 of us and we're from the
same block and we claim this block this
is our gang right
not all of us hang out and not all of us
get along the same way but there might
be five or six of us within that 200
that are our own circle
and that we hang tough and [ __ ] like
that and you know we always stood within
our circle i mean we
we were a part of everyone else too but
we were the tightest over here and for a
time yeah man i i ran
in in this one circle within our set as
we call it yeah um
and we were running [ __ ] wild i mean
um i got the name be real through
you know the gang bang life
um because before that
you know sam and i we've known each
other before that i mean since sort of
introduced me to the bangers that i
eventually
got down with but i knew sand dog way
before that because hip hop was always a
thing for us like it was a hobby that we
all
or something that we loved it wasn't
even a hobby yet
we started rapping and [ __ ] for fun and
and it did become a hobby but i sort of
straight away and got into the gangs and
and send dog and his brother melo man
nason dj muggs
they took it serious they took the music
serious they were constantly trying to
push to that
i was out there [ __ ] you know
running really wild i got shot
everything
and uh you got shot oh yeah in the lungs
well yeah it so
we were um
there was like maybe five or six of us
we were in another neighborhood another
blood neighborhood but
their neighborhood is constantly
at war with these guys that are their
rivals with their practically nav
neighbors so walking through their hood
if you don't know their get down you
might get caught up and that's what
happened you know
we didn't know how heated their little
war was in in their own neighborhood we
were oddly enough going from one house
to grab some weed to come back and party
at the house we had just left from but
we didn't take it we didn't take a strap
with us meaning a gun and uh
a car pulls up in front of us
they're all wearing blue hats
we're wearing red and [ __ ] and so as you
can imagine all the [ __ ] talking starts
and none of us are pulling anything out
and i you know i noticed that really
quickly and i saw the [ __ ]
gun coming over the front seat
and then the [ __ ] driver the the
passenger had it and he starts letting
off on us he hits one of my guys in the
elbow
the
bullet travels from the elbow and comes
out and gets stuck here
they thought they killed him because of
the way he the way he reacted when he
got hit so they switched the gun and
they're they're trying to get me now
they take four shot or he takes four
shots on me the fourth one ricochets off
the wall i run into it
so i could hear him
tucked and then the fourth one
catches up to me boom and and i caught
it
right here on the side in the back
and i didn't feel my lung collapse yet
it was when i hit the corner and i
looked to see if they got out of the car
to chase
chase us down with it but they hadn't
they kept you know they shot they kept
going
that's when i collapsed because my lung
had had been pierced
they i got hit with a 22 hollow point
still in me like there's a fragment here
fragment here and a fragment back there
so
yeah that was uh
that that happened on imperial in hoover
wow
you got hit oh i knew it was yeah it
felt like a charlie horse
when did that happen that was in 1980
oh damn maybe 85 85 86 i was 15 16 years
old wow
a lot of us at that age had gotten shot
i mean a few of my friends at that age
had just gotten out of
um
uh y.a which is a you know like a prison
yeah well it's a prison for for youth
that eventually are going to go to the
the real prison like you know there's
there's juvenile hall
and that's like a county jail for the
youth you know you're it's just
basically
you know they're holding you until they
figure out if you're going to ya or
you're going to get probation or some
[ __ ] like this right
why is the serious thing for the for the
youngsters
because it's like a prison
because it's like a prison it's a junior
prison
security gym now yeah so some of my guys
you know that were my age and in my time
they were banging they would get out
from maybe the six months or the year
that they had to do for whatever
and one of my one of my homies came out
he had he had a big reputation as young
as he was
he was known for being a shooter and
when he got out
they rode down the block
found him and they killed him that day i
think he had been out maybe a week
if that geez and that's that's how crazy
it was i mean it it it was a war zone
man got to tell you the ice cube talks
about
going to y a and hid the hood swall
yeah well that that does happen
he didn't do it you know what i mean
like he was portraying things that he's
seen in his life
from friends we've both seen that you
know what i mean i actually
lived it for a while so you know i seen
some of my homies come back like that
they you know they go in skinny young
kids and come back monsters
you know monsters ripped up 17-inch arms
at 16 years old i'm like what the [ __ ]
because i never went to y.a you know i
was fortunate enough to
you know be lucky to dodge and that was
hard for me because you know i'm like a
spanish or a latin or
you know however they want to call it
today latino whatever in in a black gang
so i'm easy to point out
i'm easy to [ __ ] track down if what
for whatever i do
so you know whatever i did i had to be
very stealth-like
and
i got lucky and didn't you know have to
get on that run but plenty of my boys
they they had to go do that time in y a
and some of them went from y a to prison
like yeah you know
they graduated as we used to call it
jesus i remember getting the sense like
back in the day hanging out that there
was like
you know
something of a of a gang element that
was like
in your
like in our circle you know like kind of
circling around yeah you know like they
wanted they wanted to be down they
wanted to like hang out and uh
you know i remember i remember a guy
named soldier yeah soldier he's still
he's still around yeah yeah and then
there's my buddy dreamer i don't know
dreamer yeah oh my god dreamers
is he he's still around i think so yeah
there that's uh see that's the odds man
and see that's the thing you know when i
got out of gang banging people knew i
did and i never was one to like
overtly tell
people or show people like oh this is
this and that gang
as as we call it set tripping you know
when you're going out of your way to let
people know i never did that because for
me i didn't want to mix
that [ __ ] into the the music world
because i knew it would be a short run
for us because you know when you got
enemies out there and now you're [ __ ]
flashing on them you're going to have a
short run you you got a big target on
your back and you got to be constantly
dodging that so i let it all go and i
never had any problems with anybody that
was
banging on the other side after that you
know what i mean we i've always got
along with any other artist that were
actual gang bangers
on the other side
always cool you know no disrespect never
but our crew
that we roll with is comprised from
people from different neighborhoods
who you know we might they might have
been a [ __ ] and now i'm a blood over
here or this he might have been a
mexican gang banger or whatever we all
roll together that's that's the dynamic
of our crew is that it's comprised of
different
folks from different streets here in in
california so when you step to us you're
stepping to not just us right and i
think that's why no one ever really
stepped to us like that one
we never were with the chips on our
shoulders like yeah come [ __ ] with us
and see what happens i think that's well
put you know thank god we were always
just chill
right for sure was there a moment that
you were like i gotta get out of this or
did it just kind of trickle away in some
way or like how does that work when i
chose the music
i knew that i could not bring the gang
banging in so i just had a talk with my
close circle of homies and said hey i'm
gonna go do this
go do it
handle that [ __ ] nice and it was as
simple as that it wasn't like i you know
i had to make a speech to 200
[ __ ] and like hey man um look
they understood and they supported me
and they had my back
in the powerpoint presentation
this is what i'm gonna do in the next my
business plan yeah yeah and now check
your slide three we got you know and and
not for nothing i mean they knew i was
trying to do something positive and for
me i was indoctrinated in gangbang and i
didn't i wasn't trying to get out
i wasn't even trying to do the music
anymore like
mugs send and and melo came to me one
day and says hey um
melo's got a record deal we need you to
help us write some [ __ ]
come back and help us right
and i didn't even think i could
at that point because i had been so
invested in in the streets at that point
like uh what am i gonna do we're gonna
make no money doing that
wow and um they're like well what do you
got to lose
and i think you know like
i i i want to be careful not to kiss
your ass but but the way the [ __ ] rap
is
people like the sound gets popular and
everybody's just sounds the [ __ ] same
it kind of drives me nuts it happens now
today still dude absolutely more today
than ever more than ever yeah more today
than ever and dude i just love like
how unique you've always been in your in
your art you know like and
dude you're to to to hear you say
that you doubted if you could write dope
[ __ ] it just it just confuses me man
well yeah you know because i hadn't
written anything in a long time and i
did most certainly didn't know how to
write a song yet i knew how to write
raps
like i was good at writing my delivery
sucked i wasn't that good
but they knew i could write and they
needed help writing
and so i came back and i did two songs
for mello's first album i think it was
uh river cubanos and tacapella or some
[ __ ] like this and they were okay songs
if you listen to them now you're like
all right
but what it did for me was it made me
realize that i could still do it i could
still write and it sort of i got bitten
by the bug like [ __ ]
the studio [ __ ] is kind of cool and and
you know at that time he was working
with delicious vinyl so in and out of
the studio would come young mc or
[ __ ] tone loke and they were cool
with us they did you know they they were
always
always very cool with us
they knew i was a gang banger so maybe
that was
part of it
just be cool with this dude because i
don't know
um
certain politeness comes with that but
you know i've always maintained respect
no matter what even if there were a [ __ ]
or whatever i never got out
of pocket with anyone in the studio
because this was business this is not
that place for that [ __ ] so i was always
focused and i was learning as i was
going along there but
i found myself wanting to be in the
studio more than on the corner
and not because of the safety because i
didn't even think about that because i
was still strapping
you know i i was we were all like
cowboys for like
i i don't know maybe
up until maybe
10 years ago we stopped like you know
cowboying it but like
we would we all of us no matter who was
with us so when we were sitting at the
rainbow oh yeah
there was at least five guns
always present
i would believe that there were plenty
of guns around you i had one on my hip
every time
you know i was a real cowboy in that
sense you know um because old habits die
hard
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude